so then in this view is there such a
thing as free will
in this view yes correct my
misunderstanding friend the way that I
understand it is that there are some
atoms moving around and occasionally
that is something we call information
processing that information processing
is much like there's a lamp right here
that is casting onto the wall that wall
is now the feeling of Consciousness that
is it's the effect and something is
happening here now that wall doesn't
cause anything with this light the light
will move around right now it's
stationary but the light can change
colors it can get brighter it can get
smashed on the ground and that wall
would change but I wouldn't say that
that wall has any causal influence on
that
so that's what I mean when I say that it
sounds like there is no free will in
what has just been outlined so please
correct my misunderstanding Okay so
let's try to talk about Free Will so so
first of all
um so Baja my partner she's a science
journalist and who's written a lot about
these topics uh I encourage you to check
out her article in the Atlantic which uh
since on the topic um but but she she
always
reminds me to think about these things
in the context of the historical
development so so pre-enlightenment
there was this idea that Free Will and
meaning and mind were
um inextricably attached to Notions like
God and the immortal soul
okay so when when those ideas started to
be questioned
was the same time that
um the materialist Paradigm arose so the
Newtonian world view of
you know
atoms bouncing around in the void
perfectly predictable Clockwork so at
the same time that we discarded or
started to discard the spiritual
and in that Gap we inserted this sort of
very first and and and and perhaps naive
um mechanistic determinism
uh Notions like Free Will which were
conjoined with God and the Soul got
thrown out with the bath water and were
replaced by the idea that that these
things are Epi phenomena of over you
know called mechanistic Universe
um so uh
so that that's one crime what is it's a
it's a a gripe with the what I think is
an over simplification of the
um approach to to thinking about
free will but but all other things
related to the mind also
um so so let me
explain why my view does and
uh suggest that Free Will is an illusion
um and so what does it mean it means
Free Will is means that you make your
your choices are your own they're not
forced On You by something else
uh
and and for any choice you make you
could have chosen otherwise
and you know the standard argument is
that
that your choices are not yours because
they're determined by the particles that
you're made of okay
so this is this this is the the argument
that you hear uh I won't mention any
names
um because
you know you so you couldn't have chosen
otherwise because the whatever the exact
position and velocity of all of your
subatomic particles uh the set and had
to evolve according to the laws of
physics or that
you know if that
you know if those particles have some
fundamental Randomness then the
randomness is still not free will
okay so that's the this argument
um and first of all let me say that that
you know that picture of physics is you
know it's right in a sense okay so I I
believe that that
subatomic particles evolve according to
the Schrodinger equation
Etc uh and the subatomic particles have
no idea that they're in a brain
or that they're part of a choice or they
represent a data structure that's part
of that that's that that data structure
feels uh as part of a choice
um
but the problem with this reductionist
argument is that it's
it's messing up its definitions and in
particular it's definitions of causality
so if we think about
um
the world is having these kind of layers
of complexity
okay you have
physics driving the atoms and chemistry
driving the molecules in biology driving
the cells then you could you could say
something like so if you want to talk
about
causality here in terms of the
hierarchies of emergence then you could
say that that quarks and electrons cause
atoms atoms cause molecules core cells
cells cause apples and brains and brains
cause Minds right
um but this is a type of causation and
it's it's like this cross hierarchical
causation
but I would argue that there's a real
fundamental difference between that type
of causation to what you might call an
an intra-hierarchical causation that
defines the Dynamics within a given
layer can you give me an example all
right so
you can say that you know there's this
causal power whereby a cell is or say a
neuron is caused by the molecules that
it's formed of
um it is an epiphenomenon of those
molecules which in turn are epiphenomena
of their atoms Etc but it's also
entirely meaningful to say that
an action potential in a neuron
causes a downstream neuron to fire
right so that's that's a reasonable
statement okay and you're on Fires one
that's attached to fires and you can you
can and and it makes total sense and and
in a real sense it's true to say that
the first neuron caused the firing of
the second
um it's
less useful to say that like
the wiggle of a Quantum string on the
Planck scale caused a downstream neuron
to fire even if the
even if the quantum string is the let's
call it the hierarchical cause of one of
the electrons in the first action
potential that's like a a roundabout and
relatively inane approach to talking
about causation so there's this this
kind of bottom-up causation in which
different levels in in
the scale of uh you know uh
physical scale or complexity scale are
generated by the the lower layers but
there's a different type of causation
within the layer okay so
um and and and within each of these
hierarchical layers you have
a a dynamics that is in a sense
independent of
the the layer below that generated it
okay so you can
um you know I mentioned Bernoulli's
equation and fluid flow so you you had
this whole field of hydrodynamics which
is beautiful and in a sense it's
causally closed Like You can predict
anything about the behavior of fluids
using these rules and
it it does matter what the properties of
the the particles in that layer are and
those properties are the properties of
those particles are generated by the
layer below but once you know the
properties of those particles you don't
care about the the the the detailed
physics of the lower below you you are
you are in that layer and the rules of
that layer are in a sense closed and
independent Okay so
so brains
have a dynamics of neural activity okay
it's a physical system they behave
like some type of neural network we can
we can even simulate it okay current
neural networks miss an awful lot but in
principle we'd be able to
run the the Dynamics of the brain with a
different substrate we can run them we
could run we one day probably will be
able to run these in silico and it and
that dynamical system the system of of
neural activity will be independent of
the substrate once we figure out what
that Dynamics is
the I don't know if you realize we've
seen such controversial statements at
saying in principle so for instance you
see in principle we could simulate the
brain substrate Independence who knows I
mean well that's like a huge offer well
I'm I'm gonna understand I'm going to
crap all over the expression in
principle I think because
um so yeah who cares we're just talking
at people who are listening just realize
that none of us have the correct words
and in order for us to just in order for
us to convey anything that's non-trivial
we're going to have to flummox a
flounder okay well I'm happy I'm happy
to put myself out there I think we will
be able to simulate the brain but it
might be a really long time away because
there's so much
and and the point is that once we once
we figure out those Dynamics it'll be
independent of the substrate silicon or
meat you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy